for as long as people have told stories
and video games
they've been trying to find ways to
better connect players with the
characters and worlds they've created
they've painstakingly labored to give
emotional weight
and deeper significance to the clusters
of code
polygons and textures that players
interact with
for hours at a time and for the better
part of
30 years games have ascended to become a
respected storytelling medium
that has created iconic and emotional
experiences
that players will never forget that's a
hell of a thing
what no
no please
hyrule
i love you i love you
now go
now that's video games at their best but
what happens when an interactive art
form rips away the choice
and turns what should be a heartfelt
moment into a cold and distant button
prompt
well you end up with a single dumbest
most
memeed upon moment in the history of
video games
[Music]
but this clunky moment from 2014's call
of duty advanced warfare
has evolved from its dank origins it's
become one of the most
powerful memes on twitch one that's
completely
separate from its original meaning one
where failure
takes center stage f's in the chat
can we get some f's in the chat f in the
chats
can we get a half in the chat for that
one boys
so every time a new call of duty is
announced we're bombarded with carefully
crafted marketing
intended to get you to buy the damn
thing and advanced warfare
was no exception despite the fact that
the game could be played on ps3
and xbox 360 advanced warfare was being
pushed as a fresh start for the
franchise
on ps4 and xbox one the future tech in
the game
is actually based on technology that we
see today
and we've taken it further that's one of
the things about call of duty it's got
to be relatable
got to be believable but we are taking
it to an extent that
makes it also fun and new advanced
warfare
leaned hard into the cinematic hollywood
eye
storytelling that 2007's modern warfare
introduced to the series and in order to
take that trademark style to the next
level
developer sledgehammer games brought in
screenwriter john mckinnis
to craft the game's narrative they're
very much interested in exploring the
sort of notion of
you know the corporatization of war what
does that look like and obviously
advanced warfare takes
takes place in 50 years time so things
that are happening now or were happening
now
what could that possibly look like in 50
years time but more than its murderous
drone swarms or the villain who shall
not be
named advanced warfare will always be
remembered for one
thing press f it leaves behind family
friends fellow marines
and a grateful nation
advanced warfare was a hit on release
but people pretty much forgot about it
as the years went on
the meme though has outlived its origins
the internet took a minor moment from a
game
and blew it up to the point where it
became a cultural
phenomenon i will try and check it out
thank you for
why i can't i can't read donations and
play at the same time it's just
impossible
press f became such a ubiquitous meme
that even
conan o'brien took the opportunity to
ridicule the ham-fisted emotion
it imposed on players hold x to pay
respect should i do it yeah
okay here we go this is a really
emotional moment for me
the funeral scene simplifies complex
feelings down to a button prompt
and ironically it's this forced
interactive element that
causes the scene to fall flat
emotionally
because by asking players to press a
button
you've moved the focus off of the
intended emotion
and onto the lame button prompt itself
now john says the button prompt was a
byproduct of late stage game development
and the giant
scale of the project so no i mean all
that stuff is sort of
out of my control as a as a writer and
conceiving that
um and it's somewhat inherent with the
sort of scale of the production because
obviously on a smaller production when
you're doing a small indie game
you know you're sitting in a in a room
with kind of your friends like
you're all being able to kind of see it
but when you're conceiving of a
you know three-year cycle of a game and
you know 20
20 or so levels and you know you know
oscar-winning talent and you know
massive massive budgets for these things
and so sometimes things get missed
at the time this scene drew comparisons
to another game that
basically did the same thing but didn't
[__] it up
nearly as bad batman arkham city
in that game if you end up in the alley
where bruce wayne's parents
died you can pay respects if you want to
the big difference is that in batman
you're not forced to press anything
the game allows you to pay your respects
it feels more
natural more immersive more organic
whereas press
f just feels wrong it reminds you that
this is all fake
and that in order to feel an emotion you
have to press a button
it's funny to think that if the
developers had just
followed the examples of other games
doing this sort of thing
well one of the internet's greatest
memes might have
never been born another instance where
button prompts actually work as intended
was with a franchise like god of war
when the game was first released back in
it too marketed itself as a grand
cinematic experience
with the player taking on the role of a
bloodthirsty anti-hero
who slaughters his way through a messed
up redemption arc
it achieved this grand sense of scale by
not just forcing you to hack and slash
your way through mythical gods
but by blending cutscenes with button
prompts that led to big sweeping moments
during the middle of these fights
the god of war button prompts were
intuitive they didn't tell you what to
do
you just hit a button and cool stuff
happened imagine it said press
x to beat the [__] out of ares that
would look
so stupid but again advanced warfare
didn't learn any lessons from its elders
and
as a result press f became an
extensively ridiculed and celebrated
meme
see these days press f has taken on an
entirely new meaning
diablo immortal
we are so excited about this
game
in today's streaming culture f's in the
chat or
literally just the letter f encompasses
a
bigger more general sense of failure
from
technical problems to xqc raging over
dumb in-game deaths eps in the chat
expresses this almost
cathartic connection between creator and
chat
so whenever somebody something up you
can almost guarantee
that f's will follow my desire to
improve the
the production here is is slipping away
by the [__] second
why you guys in the chat can just deal
with it honestly
do i have an overlay for the match timer
no what what you typing
f in the chat for camera the camera
isn't
me and greek talk a lot a friend friend
frat friend oh not not lavu
oh not coppo no
oh so
in a weird way advanced warfare's
ham-fisted attempt at creating emotional
sentiment through a button command
inadvertently spawned a new and
intuitive prompt
that achieves just that i didn't even
know about it until a journalist called
me up
and said oh you know what do you think
of this and i'm like and then i go back
and he sends me a link to the youtube
and suddenly i realized that um the
thing that you know i could
i could very well get be remembered for
is the press f meme
rather than actually writing the whole
thing
now it's difficult to pinpoint when
exactly press f to pay respects
transformed into f's in the chat but it
does appear that the popularity of the
phrase began to climb in late 2018
four years after advanced warfare's
release
hitting peak popularity in march and
april of 2020
right around the time the world went to
complete [__]
this type of evolution is the foundation
for memes
but more importantly for language as
well
and as a writer who deals with language
for a living john was happy to see the
thing he helped create
take on a second separate life you know
so it's interesting how that
has a reality i mean this meme this
journey of this
this scene this moment and the meaning
of that and it and its radiation out
into the world
and i have my intention of writing that
scene you know an actor and a director
then interpret that intention and that's
in
that intention you know hopefully it's
sort of you know instilled into the
into the game into the movie into the
experience but you know released into
the world
it takes on on whatever meaning it takes
on at the end of the day
we are the defining feature of fs in the
chat
it's the league pro who screwed up his
gank it's flam as he whiffs his op shot
while
thousands watching painful glee what
started out as a stupid button prompt
that fell
flat on its face has transformed into a
gentle reminder
that everyone messes up from the biggest
game companies to the smallest streamers
and that beautiful screw-up inspired the
internet to claim an
entire letter to celebrate failure
because as long as no one's getting hurt
we all
love watching someone [__] up
[Music]
you